hello
my name is anna dunsing i'm a phd
candidate at yale university working on
a dissertation
about anti-fascism within the civil
rights movement and black radical
theories
of fascism in the united states
from the 1930s onward and today as part
of the fortune off
video archives commemoration of black
history month
i'd like to talk to you about one aspect
of that research
which concerns african american military
service during world war
ii and more generally how soldiers and
veterans
have contributed to the black freedom
struggle across the 20th century
and within that work i want to elevate
the experiences of african american gis
who confronted nazi germany first
hand and those who really at the heart
of that experience were eyewitness to
the end
stages and immediate aftermath of the
holocaust
and for the most part um these men are
known as liberators today
that refers to soldiers who pushed into
the crumbling third reich
in the spring and summer of 1945 and who
encountered
the buchenwald dora mitchell bow
flossenberg
dachau and mao towson concentration
camps
and the fortune off is home to the
remarkable testimony of one such
soldier his name was leon bass
bass was also a lifelong educator who
spent the last four and a half decades
of his life
up until his death in 2015 he spent
those years speaking out about his
military experience
and what it meant for him to witness
buchenwald
while serving in a segregated army
really have subsequent decades of
reckoning with the holocaust
contributed to his interest in education
his involvement
in the civil rights movement and more
generally how the experience of
witnessing
this aspect this culmination of nazi
persecution
shaped his understanding subsequently of
u.s race relations and
more generally the realities of ongoing
racial violence and white supremacy in
the united states
now leon bass was born and raised in
philadelphia
he grew up in a predominantly black
neighborhood he went to all black
schools
and he describes as parents who were
sharecroppers former sharecroppers from
south carolina
they had kept him relatively sheltered
from the full force
and structural violence of racism and
jim crow segregation
in the united states however all that
changes for him when he joins the army
20 years old by the time the second
world war had become a reality
no i was and i finished school in 1943
and i was 18. and that's when i became
part of the military
and you how did you become part of the
did you volunteer you
i went out and i i volunteered and i was
to go out with the next group
and when i went down to the induction
center
institutional racism smacked me right in
the face
because the sergeant was there
and he told me to go one way
when i went through the door and he told
my white friends to go another way
because my country practices promulgated
promoted institutional racism and the
military was one of the largest
to do just that and so i went into an
all-black
unit say for the officers they were
white
but all of my comrades in arms at the
time were black
induction marked the start of a brutal
new kind of education for him
beginning with two hard and disaffecting
rounds
of basic training in the jim crow south
this was first in georgia
later in mississippi followed by
maneuvers in texas louisiana
and arkansas and this extended training
was actually typical for for
african-american gis the majority of
whom were trained in combat
before they were reassigned and
retrained in
unarmed labor units bass was assigned to
the 183rd combat engineers
and this was a time when as with
civilian life
formal and informal color lines snaked
across
every aspect of military service
white soldiers lynch mobs vigilante
groups
numerous iterations of state and local
civic and law enforcement agencies they
all policed these lines as they saw fit
at the same time jim crow lawmakers at
the state and federal levels
vowed to defend the social and political
order of jim crow
at whatever cost even u.s blood banks
remain
segregated at this time which was a hold
out of explicit racial science
so egregious so parallel to nazi race
law that it became
one of the most heated civil rights
issues of the war years
and in the case of the armed forces that
the stress and strain and insult
of these color lines became particularly
intensified right second-class
citizenship
is not tolerable to someone in uniform
someone who's risking his life for his
country
and many african-americans at this time
had observed
distinct connections between nazism and
jim crow
had recognized the parallels on the
basis of racism
white supremacy militarism empire
and attacks on organized labor so the
patriotic
rhetoric of the war right fighting in in
defense of democracy
the framing of world war ii as a war of
good versus evil
freedom versus tyranny to many
african-americans this
appeared hypocritical and rather
fraudulent
was your perception though that the
black troops generally though
fully understood the fact that while the
rhetoric of the war against nazi racism
and so forth
was fine uh in practice the country was
doing something entirely different yes
it was as though you were schizophrenic
our country had
was two personalities you know one way
we may make the wonderful pronouncements
you know we
we talk about our judeo-christian ethics
and we're going to make the world a
better place for democracy and all that
other
jazz but then when you cut down to the
real thing and you start seeing the way
they operate
uh you know things were not they were
not in consonance
and so i began to be an angry frustrated
young black soldier at this time i
wanted to get out of the army
i'll be very honest with you after my
experiences i really did not want to be
in this man's army and
especially after having to stand on a
bus
when there were no seats at the back
having to stand up for 100 miles looking
at empty seats
yeah that didn't endear me to to my
country
um couldn't eat in a restaurant i had to
go around the back and knock on the door
to get food
and i'm in a uniform i and i saw pws
prisoners of war from germany being
allowed to go in a restaurant to sit
down to eat and yet i was not entitled
to for that same opportunity
bass's battalion shipped out for europe
in october 1944
and connected with the us third army in
belgium
where they were part they fought as part
of the battle of the bulge which was the
last major german offensive campaign
on the western front and as laborers
soldiers like bass were first on the
front lines they were building roads and
bridges they were loading equipment
and supplies disabling land mines
moving the wounded and the dead and
ambassadors battalion crossed into
germany in march of 1945
and by april they had reached the
central german city of
weimar we went to weimar and
set up our bivouac area and then
went immediately with an officer about
five of us
we were in the intelligence
reconnaissance section of our unit
and we went right to buchenwald
and that was the day that i was to
discover
what had really been going on in europe
under the nazis
because i walked through the gates
and i saw walking dead people
seriously walking dead people i am not a
doctor
i cannot assess things that accurately
but
in just looking at these people who were
skin and bone
and dressed in those pajama type
uniforms their heads clean shaved
and then filled with sores
due to malnutrition and here they were
coming towards us
making all kinds of guttural statements
and
using their own language and it was very
difficult for me to comprehend
what was going on i just looked at this
in amazement and
and i said to myself you know
my god you know who are these people
what have they done what was their crime
you know
it's hard for me to try to understand
why anybody could have been treated this
way i don't care what they had done
it just didn't grab me and i didn't have
any way of thinking
or putting a handle on it no frame of
reference i was only 20.
when u.s forces discovered buchenwald
they found over 21 000 people imprisoned
there
and the days before their arrival the
germans had attempted to evacuate some
30
000 others roughly a third of whom
perished in the process
the earliest inmates at buchenwald which
opened in 1937 were political prisoners
but the german ss and police had sent
many jews there
alongside roma jehovah's witnesses
military deserters
repeat criminals and others in other
groups
and at the end of the war buchenwald was
one of roughly 44
000 camps ghettos and incarceration
sites operated by nazi germany
and its allies across europe
terms like auschwitz and bergen-belsen
and majdanek and places like that were
not
were not known to you even when i went
into bouquet i had no idea that those
places
existed those names only came to me
after i got out of the service later
much year later i began to hear of names
and places
and realized that there was more than
just a book involved
that there were many many many book
balls of different names
all over europe in russia
that's what boggles the mind to think
that
a group in society can organize and do
it in a systematic way
such a program
to remove from the world
a whole group of people and any others
that didn't seem they didn't
think were worthy like many of his
comrades
bash bass initially experienced a kind
of numbness about what he had seen
military intelligence had not prepared
soldiers for the realities of the camps
and within weeks bass was shipped off to
the philippines to finish
his service and upon return to the
united states he set forth to build a
life
all the while keeping silent about what
he had seen
he started a family pursued a phd built
his career
and became involved with the civil
rights movement
and years later the assassination of dr
martin luther king in 1968
shook him to the core it had a profound
impact on him
and in his testimony he describes the
heartache and horror
he felt in its wake particularly when he
confronted the pain and disillusionment
of many of the young black and brown
students at the high school where he
served as
a principal and one day
these present realities in the united
states and his memories of the war
collided when a visitor came to one of
his classrooms
and one day i came to a classroom
and in that classroom there was a lady
and she was trying to talk to the young
men who were not listening to her
you know they were doing everything but
listening and i stood the door and i
began to realize that she was a survivor
and she had survived one of the worst
camps she had survived auschwitz
and she was here today on this
particular day to share her experience
her pain
if you will and these young men were not
listening
they had their own pain you know and i
understood that you know the pain of
rejection the pain i'm not giving
being given the kind of recognition you
deserve i understood all of that i had
been through there
and i knew their pain but i also knew
her pain
and so i had to say to them hold it
fellas cool it
listen what she says is true i was there
and so they got quiet for a while and
once she started
telling her account of what happened at
auschwitz
they really listened and she told him
how she lost her grandmother grandfather
her parents brothers sisters cousins all
those near and dear who had come into
that camp
all of them had gone to the gas chambers
and had ended up in the ovens
and of her family she was the only one
that came out of there
and they listened she shared with him so
much
and they asked her questions which made
me know that she
had to reach them they came up looked at
the numbers tattooed on her arm and
they thanked her and they did something
i
hadn't been done in a long while they
left that room in silence
and of course she turned to me and of
course tears were coming down her face
and
she thanked me for my intervention and
and wanted to know more about my
experience at buchenwald
and i began to remember bassa's
experience was unique
but what he made of that experience and
how he and his words
began to hook things together in
subsequent decades
is instructive for us all vassa's
memories of military service and camp
liberation
and how those memories came to bear on
his interpretation of racism in the
united states it results in a call for
unity
his testimony concludes with a call for
an anti-racist coalition
building force but he also closes with a
call for vigilance
the holocaust forced a global moral
reckoning
in the united states it was a tipping
point that compelled many white
americans
to examine the state of their own
country and to get behind
african-americans demands
prevent fundamental civil and human
rights
but the realities of the holocaust also
played a significant part in forcing
white supremacists
to abandon the most explicit and
chauvinist articulations
of their world views right lest they be
associated with the unsightly
backwardness
of the recent war and it's significant
that bass re-engaged with his memories
of buchenwald around 1970.
formal narratives and institutions of
holocaust memory were on the rise in the
united states around that time
but as he so delicately puts it in his
testimony
this was a moment when many of the
promises of civil rights had begun to
falter
and the government many white americans
were clearly coming up short
in the project of reflection and
reckoning
the project of dismantling and
rebuilding their racist
foundations and bass saw that failure he
saw it
in the refusal you know of his community
to change but most especially amongst
his young students
really bass's memories open up the
possibility of
productive comparison towards solidarity
and racial justice
he asked us to consider not only what
changed after 1945 but also what
attitudes and cultures
stayed the same and in particular stayed
the same
cloaked or carried on an innuendo or in
action
[Music]
and as an educator bass concludes his
testimony um
with an important lesson for us all
and look what he did to us racism has
just about split us so many different
ways to we can't
live in harmony with one another
suspicious
all of this i discovered uh
as an adult and i didn't get it when i
was young when i should have had it
because people didn't want to deal with
it was an ugly side of our history and
ugly things we want to push under the
rug we don't want to deal with it and
i'm saying to people today
you must face it you can't laundry and
sanitize our history
you must take history with his beauty
and you must take it with its
degradation
you've got to deal with it for us to be
whole human beings and
and to make a difference and this is
especially true with young people
and so i go around telling my story and
of course i you know i get the
people saying leon what do you deal with
this this is this is not a black problem
why
i said hey it's not a black problem it's
not a white problem
it's a human problem and we've got to
face it
and as dr king says injustice anywhere
is the loss of justice everywhere you
see
words to that effect and it's true what
affects you affects
me your pain has to be my pain my pain
has to be your pain
and i must somehow convey that to the
young people
that i come to it's my commitment
and somebody says uh you you why do you
deal with that mess you know i
i said i'm sorry i know it's been 40
something years
but that doesn't make it go away it only
makes us
become more aware that we today have to
do something that
to stop that which created
the final solution and that something
is racism really racism is at the root
of all of this
under that umbrella comes bigotry and
prejudice and discrimination
unemployment
people who are unemployable large
institutions filled with those who are
drug addicts and those who are
criminals all because somehow we have
come to grips with that institution
called racism and we have to because we
see the ultimate of racism which was
what i saw at buchenwall
and so what do we do do we as educators
and
and i use it in the broadest sense
because we're all teachers of the young
in our way of life do we convey to them
the best that we can be or do we give
them
the worst side that we have do we
promote
racism through our apathy
when we hear and see things we say
nothing
because we don't want to jeopardize that
which is important to us our investment
in a job
our investment among friends we don't
want to disturb our families so
no matter what people say or do just
leave it alone sweep it under the rug
and somehow it'll go away but the
skinheads are with us
the clan is with us it may be dressed in
brooks brothers suit with attached cases
they may be in doctors they may be
lawyers they may be
the guy who drives the bus but they're
still with us